[Music]
it's like
magic you search for a product online
and all of a sudden you see it on every
platform that you have
facebook instagram tick tock and even
right here on youtube well it's not
magic it's actually artificial
intelligence working
and google is so far ahead in the
research and development of
the most advanced ai that it could very
well be the future of what artificial
intelligence will be built upon
hello and welcome back to the channel
everyone here we go
in depth with the tech world and bring
everything that is amazing about it
right in front of you hit that subscribe
button to stay up to date with all
things tech and be sure to leave a like
if you enjoyed it
let's dive in everyone knows of
artificial intelligence as being this
absolutely dangerous thing
i mean the movies paint a pretty dark
picture of what happens if someone that
utilizes artificial intelligence were to
revolt
but this is just one side view of what
artificial intelligence or
simply ai actually is google's deep mind
consists of a team of extraordinary
scientists engineers and machine
learning experts of many diversified
fields
just to name a few the group began with
the understanding that intelligence is
something that gives
us as human beings the upper hand in
life it's how we create
how we learn and through that learning
they are able to become inspired to
develop computer systems
that learn to offer solutions to
problems that may have been difficult
for others to solve
and this is done all on its own the ceo
and co-founder behind the brilliant
development is demis hasabis
it began as a simple learning ai startup
in london in 2010 alongside
shane legg and mustafa suleiman the two
hasabis and leg
met while they were doing their post-doc
work at university college london's
gatsby computational neuroscience unit
while habis and mustafa had already been
family friends
the mission of deepmind was to simply
solve intelligence and with that
intelligence solve everything else
in those early days of development early
investors came from big high profile
names
google caught wind of the team and
quickly went to purchase the company for
around 549
million dollars even with google's
purchase the company has remained an
independent entity that is based out of
london
one of the most memorable visuals that
have come from google's deepmind ai
is the video depicting the deepmind
neural network learning how to walk run
and jump the actions of the simulator
were done all from the software's
ability to learn
grow and adapt imagine being confused
about a situation or being a place to
where there is a dilemma and maybe you
cannot conceive a solution as quickly as
one would need
google's deep mind offers those
solutions
you wouldn't even have to think twice
about that challenge anymore with the
help of google's deep mind ai
replicating aside from learning how to
navigate programmed terrains deepmind
has successfully been able to not only
replicate but actually create
images from absolutely nothing but a
blank canvas
for this to be possible researchers used
imagenet as a database to provide
real-world sample images for the a.i to
learn from
this is not a relatively new algorithm
the algorithm uses generative
adversarial networks
gan a type of ai algorithm that has
existed for some time now
but what makes the deepmind ai's image
generation
unique is how much it has been able to
improve compared to the previous tests
with the algorithm
in terms of the quality metrics used to
assess artificially generated images
the samples created by deepmind's ai
outperformed other attempts by
a significant margin working with human
variables
to make things even more abundantly
clear about how much future capabilities
and possibilities are to be affected by
google's deep mind
we take one further look into its
competitive algorithm
deepmind is known for beating players at
board games and anticipating other human
players moves
but what has been improved greatly is
its ability to now do this in teams
meaning that this ai is now able to
learn and operate effectively even
considering the normal yet variable
human nature
go was created in china about 3 000
years ago
it's a pretty old and classic game in
order to win the players must utilize
multiple layers of strategical planning
the goal is to surround and capture the
opponent's stones or strategically
create spaces of territory
once all the moves that were possible
are played the player with the highest
number becomes victorious
in its early stages ais could not handle
the sheer vast amounts of possibilities
that were capable and simultaneously
compute strategical counter movements
alphago however became the first
computer program to win against a human
professional go player
over time alphago was able to improve
and become
better and better at understanding and
learning that led to much more advanced
and competitive decision making
processes
this is also known as reinforced
learning alphago went further to
becoming the first ai to also beat a
world go champion
and is now being deemed the strongest go
player in the world
the ai strategizes each move and
anticipates all
other possible movements that a human
player would make
during an announcement for the ai it was
said that through new developments and
reinforcement learning our agents have
achieved human level performance in
quake 3 arena capture the flag
a complex multi-agent environment and
one of the canonical 3d first-person
multiplayer games
deep mind set in an announcement these
agents demonstrate the ability to team
up with both artificial agents
and human players validity
after a brief partnership with the
moorefields eye hospital in london
deepmind's ai learned how to detect and
correctly diagnose over
50 eye diseases this was achieved by
having deep mind analyzing thousands of
scans
this includes glaucoma macular
degeneration and other diseases that
cause visual impairment researchers said
that the ai showed performance in making
a referral recommendation that reaches
or exceeds that of
experts of course we understand that
computers will not be putting doctors
out of a job anytime soon but to be able
to see the amazing accomplishments of
this at such a youthful stage is
absolutely astonishing
it was even reported that through the
medical testing of the visual impairment
that google was extending its research
into breast cancer screening as well
the world is seeing this technology grow
at a rapid rate currently
deep mind's ability to succeed also
comes from the vast numbers of
differentiating fields
they are constantly growing the team and
bringing different perspectives that can
address differing situations
computer science neuroscience ethics and
public policy to responsibly pioneer aei
systems the possibilities the
possibilities become
endless with what deep mind is able to
produce currently one of the main
highlights of the program is
understanding protein folding
learning and understanding how proteins
fold will help scientists and
researchers get a better comprehension
of all living organisms
to accelerate that process a system
named alpha fold was created to
accurately predict the shape of proteins
as confusing as it may seem it has
massive potential in every field of
biology when dealing with disease
treatments and even unlock new
opportunities for areas to improve on
when dealing with life
itself challenges
running multi-million dollar ai isn't
cheap and one absolutely massive issue
at hand is the costs associated with the
research and development
in 2018 the program spent over 750
million dollars according to the
financial times
the funds went towards mostly salaries
for the 838 employees
additionally there is the seemingly
overbearing billion dollar debt that is
owed to google
there are not concerns of default at
this time yet it is still a fact that
the company is facing
another factor in some of the challenges
that are focused on the public's view is
the departure of high-level executives
this can pose an issue in the public
side that can severely hurt the
company's profit
summary artificial intelligence is the
future
we use forms of it in our everyday lives
it's in our jobs
our homes our phones cars and one day
maybe even in our clothes
think of the day that your shirt or coat
can sense your body heat and make
changes to how tight or loose it may
become
depending on your learned behavior it
can seem a tad creepy at first but in
reality
it may be what actually sets us so far
into the world of possibilities that we
can't even conceive what would be next
deep mind isn't just a regular ai it is
the future of ai
as we know it thanks for watching and as
always if you enjoyed what you just saw
leave a like and press that subscribe
button to stay in the know of what you
need to know thanks see you next time